[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas este 20 de marzo de
2023 se cumplieron 20 años de la
invasión estadounidense de Irak el país
entró en una espiral de violencia que
tuvo su momento más crítico entre el
2006 y el 2008 cuando se vivió una
guerra civil que pasó a conocerse como
la guerra sectaria que dejó cientos de
miles de muertos y a una sociedad
totalmente fragmentada durante años
cientos de miles de personas tuvieron
que abandonar sus casas en Bagdad para
buscar refugio en barrios dominados por
su secta chiítas o sunitas para muchos
esta ha sido la época más dolorosa y
Sangrienta de todas las que ha vivido
Irak desde el inicio de la invasión el
siguiente es un informe de nuestra
enviada especial Catalina
cada barrio de Bagdad ha quedado marcado
por las diferentes guerras que han
devastado el país desde la invasión
estadounidense en 2003
en esta casa de sader City vive la
familia del mustafa allazari que fue
linchado y ahorcado por el estado
islámico
después de que daish avanzó por el país
y el ayatolá proclamó una fatua para
unirse a su defensa mustafa pidió
permiso a mis padres para luchar contra
los asesinos
las imágenes de su hermano siendo
exhibido en la ciudad de faluya antes de
ser ejecutado revivieron en esta familia
el dolor de la guerra sectaria que
desangró Irak entre 2006 y 2008
algunos hombres levantan la mano en
señal de aprobación y su hermano en el
medio como un trofeo
sentimos mucha tristeza porque mustafa
fue a esta región a defenderlos si
vienes zonas unita es tierra iraquí su
responsabilidad es defenderla
el asesinato de mustafa destruyó a esta
familia su padre murió meses después y
su madre apenas puede ponerse de pie
después de la invasión nos sentimos bien
Por poco tiempo luego Todo fue un caos
empezaron a matarse unos a otros
imán Recuerda que durante años los
unitas y chitas se mataron entre ellos
cuenta que en esta calle de este barrio
sunita aparecía muertos todos los días
la familia de sugerir fue una de las
tantas que tuvo que buscar refugio en
este barrio sunita después del asesinato
de su esposo en 2006 la guerra sectaria
desplazó a cientos de miles de personas
dentro de la ciudad en busca de la
protección de los suyos
[Música]
vivíamos en la lucha una zona de mayoría
Chita nos mandaban amenazas pero mi
esposo se rehusó a irse Porque habíamos
comprado la casa nos mandaron avisos más
de una vez hasta que se lo llevaron de
su almacén
miles de mujeres como suhar han quedado
viudas en estos años de guerra Ha
logrado educar a sus hijos gracias a
organizaciones como las que dirige imán
teive la mayor recibirá el título de
abogada en pocos meses pero le preocupan
especial el futuro de sus dos hijos
varones en un país cada vez más
empobrecido
[Aplausos]
en Colombia El acuerdo de paz entre las
FARC y el gobierno redujo
significativamente la violencia en las
zonas de conflicto y con ello abrió la
oportunidad de encontrar territorios
escondidos que hoy son joyas turísticas
por descubrir El Cañón del guape en el
departamento del meta espera ser una de
las grandes atracciones del país para
que su municipio la Uribe pase de ser la
antigua capital de las FARC a una nueva
potencia del turismo el siguiente es un
informe de Juice Muñoz y aitor chavarre
chicos
Carlos Cruz es guía va a acompañar a un
grupo hasta las profundidades de un
cañón que llega a los 120 metros
la que nosotros recomendamos es esta
posición
hasta hace poco más de un año no era
habitual ver turistas en la zona
bastante esta parte y le queda más
ajustadito si quieren dicen que en los
llanos de Colombia Se mira lejos a
diferencia de la Cordillera pero no hace
tanto el conflicto armado escondía las
Maravillas naturales del departamento
del meta en el centro de Colombia como
El Cañón del guape no es que ni siquiera
la cascada del amor que queda cinco
minutos apoyamos conocer Pues por el
tema de minas por el tema de conflicto
Carlos tiene 31 años es desplazado y
víctima del conflicto armado su hermano
entró en la guerrilla y nunca más
tuvieron noticias los jóvenes de la
Uribe encuentran en el atractivo que
despierta el cañón una alternativa a la
violencia no la primera vez que bajé uno
baja de locos o sea esto es algo que
usted dice Wow esto Realmente está en mi
municipio está canurier como quien dice
no me lo creo
las FARC tenían gran poder en la Uribe
de ahí la desconexión con el estado una
herencia palpable en sus vías precarias
Natanael rojas llegó a la Uribe cuando
todo era selva era el año 1966 nunca se
ha ido pese haber estado en el centro de
la guerra no me daba miedo porque
exactamente
yo consideraba que que yo no no tenía
por qué irme de una región Donde
había logrado hacer en la juventud lo
que tenía hoy en día y yo pensaba en eso
Natanael nunca pensó que su casa podría
ser un lugar atractivo para personas de
todo el mundo Aquí es donde llegan los
turistas
a disfrutar de
de esta belleza
Natanael como la Uribe escribió su
historia en las sombras ahora
silenciando los fusiles espera que la
antigua capital de las FARC se convierta
en la capital del turismo en Estados
Unidos aumenta el enfrentamiento entre
Estados por los derechos de los niños
trans cada territorio decide sus propias
reglas en este tema existen más de 40
proyectos de ley impulsados en
territorios bajo control republicano que
pretenden prohibir o incluso
criminalizar con pena de cárcel la
transición sexual en menores de 18 años
o el uso de bloqueadores de pubertad del
otro lado en los Estados demócratas como
Nueva York buscan convertir la ciudad en
un santuario de tratamientos transgénero
pediátricos nuestra corresponsal
mamenzala nos trae la historia
noela tiene 11 años y es una de las
niñas transgénero más jóvenes de Estados
Unidos su padre asegura que a los dos
años ya dejaba Claro que su identidad
femenina no conectaba con su cuerpo de
niño
cuando tenía alrededor de dos años es
cuando empezó a decir no soy un niño soy
una niña la gente le decía Oh Qué niño
más lindo y ella no no soy un niño soy
una niña y a los 4 años y medio fue a su
primer terapeuta especializado de
transgénero Y le dijimos Ahora eres una
chica a los 7 años se cambió legalmente
el nombre
al igual que noela en Estados Unidos hay
más de 300.000 niños que se identifican
como trans muchos de ellos sufren el
acoso de la sociedad y esto los lleva a
dudar de cómo se sienten no no siempre
he estado tan segura
solo comencé a creer en mí misma y a
creer que podía hacer cosas Aunque
hubiera otra gente que me dijera que no
[Música]
por eso no él ha compartido con el mundo
como le implantaban unos bloqueadores de
pubertad que ahora muestra con orgullo
alimentando un debate que divide a
Estados Unidos
debería permitirse a un menor ser trans
la doctora Gloria pop trabaja en este
centro de defensa del colectivo lgtbiq
aquí ayudan a los menores a comprender
su identidad de género Por supuesto
porque ellos quieren ser capaces de ser
quienes quieren ser no se hacen
preguntas en este espacio vienen aquí
les preguntamos Por qué nombre quieren
ser llamados les preguntamos cuál es su
nombre para eso juegan un papel
fundamental los padres del menor que
suelen acudir a centros como este en
busca de información para que sus hijos
no sufran
depresión suicidios niños dañándose a sí
mismos es muy común en esta comunidad
los niños de este grupo se quitan la
vida constantemente porque nadie los
escucha nadie los ve la mayoría de los
padres cuando llegan aquí todo lo que
dicen es Quiero que mi hijo esté seguro
no era siempre ha contado con el apoyo
de su padre que además es su madre
biológica junto se han propuesto luchar
por sus derechos en un país donde hay
más de 40 proyectos de ley en contra de
la transexualidad infantil
en España la primera Ley de bienestar
animal a nivel esta que acabo de ser
aprobada excluye a los perros de casa y
a los que realizan actividades como el
pastoreo o que formen parte de los
cuerpos de seguridad del Estado Aunque
estos animales quedaron por fuera de la
ley en sí que pone límites por ejemplo a
la cantidad de horas en que pueden estar
desatendidos la reforma del Código Penal
paralela que implica mayores penas por
maltrato si les ampara nuestra
corresponsal en Madrid Mariana Colorado
habló con cazadores pastores y con una
asociación que recibe a perros de casa
abandonados sobre esta nueva legislación
que entrará en vigor en septiembre
Apache es uno de los perros cazadores de
Salvador es un Pointer o perro de
muestra su labor es apuntar Dónde se
encuentra la presa y una vez muerta
buscarla y traérsela al cazador para
Salvador su perro es como su hijo pero
siente que los cazadores están mal
vistos por la sociedad y más ahora que
los animales de caza no están incluidos
en la ley de bienestar animal aprobada
en España nosotros vivimos por y para la
naturaleza conservamos la naturaleza
conservamos el monte cuidamos de
nuestros animales no lo abandonamos como
se suele decir que abandona un perro no
a un cazador desde la federación
madrileña de caza no niegan que exista
el abandono o el maltrato en la práctica
cinegética Pero en ningún caso la
defienden a nosotros estaremos siempre
en contra Y denunciaremos ante los
tribunales cualquier maltrato a
cualquier animal sin embargo este
maltrato y abandono lo ve a diario
maricarmen Ven aquí de los 300 perros
que viven en este albergue el 99% llegó
de la mano de cazadores que ya no los
necesitaban
Tenemos un montón de perros sumamente
viejitos que los han traído para no
pagar el sacrificio del animal
claramente bajo la nueva ley el
sacrificio injustificado y el abandono
están penados incluso para los cazadores
los pastores también están exentos de
algunas restricciones que impone la ley
para ellos y sus perros tumba odín
Álvaro que trabaja con ovejas desde hace
más de 20 años cree que estas leyes
están hechas desde una cosmovisión
urbana que olvida la simbiosis milenaria
entre animales y humanos ellas forman
parte de nuestra civilización también es
que y gracias a ellas y a ellos a los
perros y a los caballos que han
trabajado También
tenemos estamos donde estamos una
utilidad a cambio de protección cuidados
y respeto mutuo las bases de lo que
todos ellos consideran el verdadero
bienestar animal
queremos agradecer a Jim Garden en la
ciudad de Bogotá por prestarnos sus
instalaciones para realizar este
programa ustedes también Muchas gracias
por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información
[Música]